the second fantastic beast film brings
together the story of Newt Scamander
and his old professor Albus Dumbledore
throughout fans can find a ton of Easter
eggs hidden throughout the movie but
only the truest Harry Potter aficionados
are bound to catch pull out you wand and
get your ante spoiler spell ready here
are the small details you missed in
fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald in the crimes of Grindelwald
there's a lot to unpack about the
relationship between the titular villain
and his opposite equal Albus Dumbledore
Dumbledore visit to the mirror of Erised
said that this help reveal some of the
major points in it he sees his younger
self or making a Blood Pact with the boy
he says he was closer than brothers
worth not only does that call back a
similar scene from Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's Stone when the boy wizard
summons up a happier image of his
parents it also earns a more subtle bit
of nostalgia from the original series
thanks to who we see in it actors Toby
regbo and Jamie Campbell Bower reprised
their roles as Dumbledore and
Grindelwald and fantastic beats - after
having portrayed the characters ever so
briefly in Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows Part 1 considering how small
their screen time was in the original
series they could have easily been
replaced but seeing them return to these
roles nicely bridges the gap between the
film sets the sweeping new shots of an
unfettered Hogwarts probably made for a
very welcome sight for Harry Potter fans
who cringe with every artifacts
destruction in the second Wizarding war
in Deathly Hallows part-2
the bridge is shown intact the Great
Hall is perfectly lit by floating
candles and of course Dumbledore's
office is still filled of so many of his
intriguing tools of the trade the scenes
involving young Dumbledore also featured
a few name drops that will reign
familiar to fans
first there's the instructions for the
students to go with Professor McGonagall
who we all know and love so well from
the Harry Potter series then the one
students name is called out as McLaggen
who must be the ancestor of this
Gryffindor student from the original
series
Cormac McLaggen fantastic beasts the
crimes of Grindelwald also turned what
we knew about an old Harry Potter
character on its head when it revealed
that Nagini was not always a snake
sidekick of the Dark Lord
instead as she was formerly a person of
the maledictis curse which meant that
she shape-shifted into snake form and
one day would not be able to change back
there's a running theory that she might
turn out to be Tom Riddle's actual
mother before it's all said and done it
would certainly help explain the
allegiance she develops for the
character later on not to mention his
eventual snaky features and his gift
with Parseltongue especially if she were
to say conceived of older more with
credence on the other hand at the books
and films have already established two
riddles parentage so of their fantastic
beasts films decide to go a different
direction they'll have a whole lot of
explaining to do Harry Potter fans may
have previously only known of Nicolas
Flamel thanks to Harry Hermione and Ron
discovering how he created the
Philosopher's Stone and achieved
immortality or at least really really
long life in the first installment
however fantastic beasts - gives us a
fuller glimpse of the character in his
Crone like decrepit form as well as a
quick glimpse of the elusive
Philosopher's Stone in Flamel house but
unlike most of Rowling's characters the
Flamel was actually a real person and
was rumored to have used alchemy to
become a mortal Jake was oh oh you don't
look a day over 375 the end of fantastic
beasts the crimes of Grindelwald
features a big twist
where we finally learn about credence
his family history after narrowly
escaping capture in the first film he
spends this movie trying to track down
the identity of his real parents and
figure out why they decided to leave him
in the care of a horrible woman like
Mary Lou barebone in the end he
discovers that he isn't the long-lost
sibling of Lita Lestrange as he'd
expected but that he was actually named
or Elias Dumbledore and that Albus
Dumbledore is trying to destroy him
according to Grindelwald if there's one
thing these Wizarding World stories love
its family drama and the revelation that
credence could actually be related to
Dumbledore it's a good stuff fans of the
franchise are probably poring over their
books to see if they can figure out
where this new information fits into the
ever-expanding Harry Potter universe if
only hearing the actors say the name
Dumbledore with such gravitas didn't
sound quite so
ridiculous
[Music]